I think it's scary that like Donald
Trump it feels like for all of the
accusations that are made sometimes
against Democrats like Biden is ordering
uh Garland to investigate Donald Trump
and blah blah blah uh it seems like
Donald Trump would actually do that with
his doj would give them orders he didn't
he didn't he he kind of did though right
um so for instance with um Jeffrey Clark
uh Jeffrey Clark went to Rosen and
Donahue and said Hey listen uh I need
you guys to sign off on a letter that
we're going to use to bully States into
overturning their elections by saying we
found significant election fraud and
part of that threat was Jeffrey Clark
saying listen if you're not going to do
it Rosen uh you know Trump's going to
fire you and just make me the acting
attorney general that was a threat that
he carried and I think Trump repeated
that threat in a meeting later on that
was I only rebuked when I think like
half the White House staff said if you
do this were resigning okay so that's a
slightly different topic because now
you're getting into all the election
Shenanigans and all this but I'm saying
he threatened to fire his acting
attorney general if he wouldn't carry
the same platform essentially like if
Trump could order his doj to do
something would he
um it's not Beyond The Pale for him
right it's not Beyond The Pale for him
to order them to do it and then it's not
Beyond The Pale for them to reject him
doing that which is the story of his
entire Administration whereas Joe Biden
orders his doj to do things and then
they just do them well I'm not we can
get into specifics there um I I just I
it this's one of the big problems that I
have with I mean for example all the
talk about Trump Ty rant Trump executive
power I mean Joe Biden has used
executive power in ways that far outrip
every president has been stretching and
stretching and stretching executive
power Jo Joe Biden is going like
Joe Biden has gone well beyond anything
Trump even remotely attempted to
maintain via just pure executive power
and actually Trump's use of executive
power is nowhere near even what Obama's
was Trump inability to get border policy
pass literally had him using executive
power to to March the military down to
the border to do border policy I mean I
mean Joe Biden literally used the
occupational safety and Hazard
Administration to try to cram down vax
mandates on 80 million Americans that's
insane he literally said I cannot
relieve student loan debt and then tried
to
relieve hundreds of billions of dollars
in yeah but what happened to that it got
struck down by the Supreme Court and
then they still did it they still did it
Biden brags about it for for for what he
for what he was able to for what he was
able to relieve which I think were
related to particular type student loan
debt but I'm just saying that like well
the guard rails are holding with Biden
as much as they're holding with Trump
the only difference is is that once
Biden you know exhausts his executive
power he's not running around like lying
to people or trying to extort people or
trying to and concoct insane schemes
well I mean so here here's the way I
would think of this think of the guard
rails holding as the filter okay meaning
like the the coffee is in the filter
some of it's you know what you want is
going to get through and all this stuff
the guard rails prevent the other stuff
from getting through now the question
becomes what liquid are you pouring into
the filter okay meaning so if I if I'm
if if the filter exists if the guard
rails hold and if Donald Trump can't
steal elections what's the policy that
comes through the other end of the
filter the policy I get from Donald
Trump on the other end of the filter is
a bunch of stuff that I like the policy
that I get from Joe Biden on the other
end of the filter is a bunch of
I don't so that's the basic calculation
okay so so then the idea is essentially
that Donald Trump's rhetoric is insane
but we don't care um Donald Trump would
probably try to steal an election if he
could but he probably won't be able to
um he's not goingon to do it again I
told you he's not you don't you don't
think he has any why not because he
won't be eligible to be on the ballot in
I mean by the way you want to talk about
14th Amendment that's where the 14th
amendment applies okay that that's where
it actually applies meaning you cannot
he is not qualified to be on the ballot
in 2028 if he is the president of the
United States states can literally in
self-executing fashion take him off the
ballot just like he's past the age of 35
once you have been president two times
you're no longer eligible to be
president of the United States why then
you have a strong little keep off the B
why the why would the 14th Amendment
stop if he thought vice president Pence
could unilaterally decide the outcome of
the election that when he's not on the
ballot so so now now your theory is that
he's going to get he's going to get
reelected and then in 2028 he's not even
going to be on the ballot and he's going
to direct his new vice president K Lake
to Simply declare him president of the
United States when he has not been on a
ballot I don't know what the I don't
know what the scheme would be I think I
think we can kind of like laugh and say
there's no scheme we could even concoct
but I think like with the machine gun
he's going to walk I think I think the
issue though is that like the idea of
electing another president that has
tried to circumvent the peaceful
transfer of power using extra legal
means and then pretending like we can't
concoct a single scheme that he could
try to circumvent um other legal
processes to have a third term or to
have a longer term or to uh install who
he wants as the next president I just
when a when a person has already shown
you who they are and with every single
person around him agrees with that when
every single person that's worked with
him save for the what Sydney pal uh
Eastman and Giuliani which I don't think
even I don't think anybody would want to
throw their lot in with those three um
it just seems wild to me that we would
say like yeah we're just going to go
ahead and trust this guy with another
ter of president but like he can't run
for a third term so it's fine when
there's like 50 million other things
make you the case that if you want him
not to make election trouble you should
elect him president in the next election
cycle and then he will be ineligible
that okay well find that be aolly
unconvincing argument but
okay